wahrscheinlich wurde in der letzten zeit
kaum etwas zu heftig diskutiert wie das
verbot von dieselautos in deutschen
innenstädten nach hamburg wird es ab
2019 wohl auch aachen in
nordrhein-westfalen treffen und in
absehbarer zeit wahrscheinlich auch noch
weitere innenstädte also hier das pro
und contra für diesel oder gegen diese
fahrverbote in deutschen innenstädten
sind diese fahrverbote alternativlos um
die luft in den städten besser zu machen
oder handelt es sich um eine reine
symbol handlung wäre es wirklich
verantwortlich und was wird in zukunft
auf uns zukommen das alles und noch viel
mehr
jetzt bei pixum science fiction herzlich
willkommen
ja ein thema das hätte ich ihnen der
whatsapp community diskutiert wurde und
deshalb jetzt das video hier dazu nach
hamburg jetzt also auch noch waren
anfang juni hat das verwaltungsgericht
entschieden und einer klage der
deutschen umwelthilfe stattgegeben und
so gibt es auch für die bezirksregierung
köln keine schonfrist mehr sie muss
dafür sorgen dass der grenzwert für
stickstoffdioxid ab dem 1 1 2009 10
eingehalten wird die stadt aachen
überschreitet regelmäßig und deutlich
den grenzen der bei 40 mikrogramm pro
kubikmeter luft liegt wie genau die
stadt diese auflage umsetzt ist ihre
eigene sache aber hier wird wohl ähnlich
in hamburg kein weg an diesel
fahrverboten vorbeiführen anders als in
der hansestadt dürfte es hier allerdings
nicht reichen wenn einzelne strecken für
diese fahrzeuge gesperrt werden es wird
wohl zu einem flächendeckenden verbot
kommen dann will man abwarten und
schauen was die werte sagen im fall der
fälle müssten dann im herbst 2009 10
auch diesel mit euro-5-norm aus der
stadt gesperrt werden von einem diesel
fahrverbot kann nur abgewichen werden
wenn es genügend andere maßnahmen gibt
die schadstoffbelastung anderweitig
eindämmen können
das sagt das grundsatzurteil des
leipziger bundesverwaltungsgerichtes vom
25.10.2011 18 und gibt so den
rechtlichen rahmen für ganz deutschland
vor aber ihr wisst selbst auch andere
deutsche städte sind mit hochdruck daran
die luftreinhaltepläne zu optimieren und
umzusetzen
die deutsche umwelthilfe hat nämlich in
27 weiteren städten darunter sind auch
düsseldorf frankfurt am main münchen
berlin stuttgart essen gelsenkirchen und
so weiter und so fort und das urteil zur
stadt aachen gilt hier als
richtungsweisend dazu schreibt die
deutsche umwelthilfe auf ihrer website
luftverschmutzung ist nach wie vor eines
der größten umweltprobleme unserer zeit
trotz europaweit geltende gesetze und
dem recht auf saubere luft werden die
grenzwerte für gesundheitsschädliche
luftschadstoffe wie stickstoffdioxid
oder feinstaub in vielen städten und
ballungsräumen regelmäßig überschritten
dies belastet die gesundheit der bürger
und schadet unserer umwelt und dem klima
bis zu 95 prozent der menschen in den
städten europa seien
schadstoffkonzentration ausgesetzt die
ernst zu nehmen
etliche schäden zur folge haben
hervorgerufen hauptsächlich durch
industrie und verkehr die deutsche
umwelthilfe bezieht sich auf studien der
europäischen umweltagentur nach denen es
im jahr 2014 mehr als 420.000 vorzeitige
todesfälle gegeben hat die man alle auf
die feinstaubbelastung in der luft
zurückführen kann hinzu kommen knapp
80.000 todesopfer aufgrund hoher
stickstoffdioxid konzentration
gesundheitliche schäden verursachen
kosten bis zu 940 milliarden euro also
bis zu neun prozent des
bruttoinlandsproduktes der eu
die umwelthilfe plädiert dafür alle zehn
millionen diesel-pkw der abgasstufe 5
und 6 mit neuen katalysatoren
nachzurüsten und zwar auf kosten der
hersteller
der deutsche städtetag also der
zusammenschluss von rund 3.400 städten
und gemeinden mit knapp 52 millionen
einwohnern lehnt diesel fahrverbote ab
der verband sieht die bundesregierung in
der pflicht sie solle die autoindustrie
in die pflicht nehmen und nicht nur
software updates sondern auch hardware
nachrüstungen verpflichtend machen viele
städte und kommunen meinen dass sie die
grenzwerte für stickstoffdioxid selbst
bei einem absoluten fahrverbot und
einführung einer blauen plakette nicht
einhalten könnten
doch das ist kein wunder wenn man sich
das beispiel hamburg anschaut hier
gelten die diesel fahrverbote an zwei
besonders belasteten straßenabschnitten
nämlich 600 meter der max brauer allee
in der not diesel mit der euro-6-norm
weiterfahren dürfen und einmal 1,7
kilometer in der stresemannstraße wo das
verbot ausschließlich ältere diesel lkw
betrifft bei verstößen sind pkw fahrer
25 euro los und lkw-fahrer 75 euro
ausgenommen sind anwohner und der sucher
müllwagen lieferfahrzeuge
rettungsfahrzeuge und taxis die
fahrgäste aufnehmen oder absetzen knapp
24.000 in hamburg gemeldete fahrzeuge
sind wohl vom diesel fahrverbot
betroffen
doch welche alternativen gibt es um die
schadstoffkonzentration in den
innenstädten zu senken gibt es viele
möglichkeiten beispielsweise die
anschaffung von elektrobussen oder apa
die nachrüstung von diesel busflotte
müsste der öffentliche nahverkehr
attraktiver gemacht werden
beispielsweise indem mitarbeiter an
günstige jobtickets kommen auch der
fahrradverkehr kann gefördert werden
beispielsweise durch den umbau der
hauptverkehrsadern städte wie berlin
wollen jetzt selbst gegen diese
fahrverbote vorgehen beispielsweise
durch mehr elektromobilität mehr
tempo-30-zonen und den ausbau der
elektro fahrzeug flotten jetzt erst
einmal haben die verkehrsminister von
bund und ländern beschlossen die
zugehörigen stickoxid messstationen
unter die lupe zu nehmen schließlich sei
es wichtig zu wissen ob die messungen
überhaupt ordnungsgemäß verlaufen
schließlich drohen strafzahlungen von
kommunen und städten richtung brüssel
am ende lässt sich festhalten dass die
gesundheit der menschen in den städten
an erster stelle steht die grenzwerte
sind keine lose empfehlung an die man
sich mal mehr mal weniger halten kann
doch letztendlich müsste die
bundesregierung jetzt mal ran um eine
bundesweite regelung festzusetzen denn
gerichtsurteile werden jetzt stück für
stück auch andere deutsche städte dazu
zwingen fahrverbote zu verhängen die
diese allerdings kaum umsetzen
geschweige denn kontrollieren können
doch das fatale ist die überschreitung
der grenzwerte passieren regelmäßig und
sind kein geheimnis das heißt also die
fakten sind bekannt dass heißt industrie
und politik seien sind an diesem chaos
schuld zudem darf die politik auch nicht
vergessen wer dahintersteckt autos und
ihre hersteller die spätestens jetzt
verpflichtet werden müssten saubere
antriebe und massentaugliche
elektroautos auf den markt zu bringen
politik und autoindustrie haben mir
einfach versagt und jetzt für dieses
chaos gesorgt
reine schadensbegrenzung in sachen diese
krise bringt uns jetzt gar nichts das
bisherige fahrverbot in hamburg ist
jedenfalls nicht mehr als ein reines
zahlenspiel keine spur von nachhaltigen
umweltschutz denn vielleicht werden die
emissionen so dort langfristig unter den
grenzwert gelangen doch der verkehr wird
nur umgeleitet in weniger belastete
straßen heißt also die stickoxide werden
umverteilt und keineswegs verringert man
könnte das in hamburg also tatsächlich
als bloßen aktionismus bezeichnet mit
dem die eu
besänftigt werden soll und
strafzahlungen abgewendet werden sollen
denn die drohen jetzt noch zusätzlich
wenn ihr keine videos zur
luftverschmutzung und zu allen anderen
themen verpassen wollt dann endet mich
bei whatsapp dann um geht ihr die
kaputte abo box hier auf youtube um
verpasst kein video
denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir
noch vor allen anderen vom neuesten
video täglich und garantiert einfach
hier draufklicken und am besten auch
meinen schwesterkanal klicks um social
and media abonnieren da gibt es das
neueste aus der social media welt dafür
hier klicken aber nicht die blogger
vergessen und wie geht es weiter mit
dafür auch draufklicken diese skandal
autoindustrie verantwortlich für
zehntausende tote
bis dann bleibt dran